a shocking act of violence has ripped
yet another american town to pieces an
18-year-old gunman stormed an elementary
school in uvalde texas tuesday afternoon
and opened fire salvador romas
an 18 year old male who resided in
uvalde
it's believed that he abandoned his
vehicle and entered into
the robb elementary school in new valley
with a handgun and he may have also had
a rifle as of now no motive is known for
the mass shooting
the 600 children who attended the
primary school were aged from five or
six to about 12 years old at this point
the investigation is leading to tell us
that the suspect did act alone during
this hyenas crime
the killings come less than 10 days
after a gunman who posted racist rants
online killed 10 people at a grocery
store in buffalo new york
gun laws in texas are among the least
restrictive in the country
there's no minimum
age
limit
for
children to possess
firearms
in texas
the u.s averages about 10 mass shootings
per week nearly 200 mass shootings have
happened so far this year that includes
27 school shootings these kids weren't
unlucky
this only happens in this country
and nowhere else
nowhere else do little kids go to school
thinking that they might be shot that
day
the murders of the school children in
uvalde brought this response from
president joe biden
when in god's name
are we going to stand up to the gun
lobby
when in god's name
we do we all know in our gut needs to be
done
despite polls that show a majority of
americans favor tougher gun laws the
efforts to pass national gun legislation
have been blocked time and time again by
republicans and a few democrats in
congress
with an estimated
390 million guns owned by civilians in
the u.s and few effective limits on gun
ownership the horror in uvalde will
likely be repeated again and again
rob reynolds al jazeera